how is documentary filmmaking evolved
you look at something like Grey Gardens
which was beautiful in its own right but
then you see something like searching
for sugar man
and it seems like filmmaking nowadays is
so much faster the editing is just
quicker how have we changed as an
audience so that filmmaking is what it
is in terms of this fast cutting well
it's it is it reflects the same kind of
a attention span that all forms of
filmmaking commercial making television
all of that is becoming faster so Grey
Gardens is going to look slow so yes
everything is faster if you look at Grey
Gardens it is of a different era and
it's also cinema verite which is
supposedly a flight now fly-on-the-wall
style of filmmaking some would argue
that you're never flying the wallet in a
minute you have a cameraman in a room
you're influencing the events but we
talk about different styles of
documentaries and in the class and
cinema verite is certainly one of the
earlier forms of documentary filmmaking
where you're just observing an event
searching for sugar man is something
much what's much more constructed or
you're adding visual and aural textures
to it you're using music in a very
dramatic way you're using sound effects
in a very dramatic way a graphics
animation Errol Morris does the same
thing with his montages you're actually
constructing scenarios to support your
story that are completely constructed
completely created by the filmmaker
there's a several sequences in the fog
of war
Errol Morris takes what normally would
have been just a picture of a b-29 over
Tokyo but because he likes to construct
his documentaries he'll cut the plane
out he'll make the props spin around and
he'll he'll just do things that kind of
take you to a different place so you're
observing it in a different way it's
more of an entertainment style but it's
also more of a you're kind of looking at
it in a different way than perhaps the
documentary you would see on BBC about
world war 2 so there are different
styles that the cutting is faster today
no doubt about it and the other document
is we talk about you know the so there
was a cinema
cinéma vérité which is observational
then there's something that might be
called participatory which is the kind
of filmmaking that Michael Moore does or
Morgan Spurlock where the filmmaker
doesn't pretend that he's a fly on the
wall in fact it's the exact opposite he
they become part of the action they
they're a character in their own movie
and then there's the more routine or
documentary we see on television is like
frontline and that's kind of an
expository style where you have the
voice of God narrator taking you down
the path Ken Burns does that as well so
we look at the different styles of
documentaries and we also look on in
every one of those forms things are
faster things do move quicker and yet
sometimes you can you can play against
that and slow it down to effect so
there's always of context for you know
the way you're you're shooting and
cutting a documentary
you